today on the matt well show we have
reported on many doctors who butcher
children but today i'll tell you about
the worst one yet this one says he does
not abide by any age limit at all none
also joe biden tries to rewrite history
and cast the democrats as the party of
law and order the democratic governor of
minnesota also tries to rewrite history
claiming that the school shutdowns never
happened we all imagined it apparently a
brave young man shows up at a girls
basketball tournament and completely
dominates in our daily cancellation
we'll deal with the pundit who has
decided to die on the hill of defending
gender surgeries for children all of
that and more today on the matt wells
show
[Applause]
[Music]
hiring is challenging especially right
now when you have so much on your plate
luckily there's one place you can go
where hiring is simple fast and smart a
place where growing businesses connect
to qualified candidates that place is
ziprecruiter.com
walsh zip recruiter
does the work for you zip recruiter uses
its powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates with your job
you can easily review uh these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply zip recruiter is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
no wonder zip recruiter is the number
one rated hiring site based on g2
satisfaction ratings as of january 1
2022 and right now to try zip recruiter
for free my listeners can go to
ziprecruiter.com
walsh that's ziprecruiter.com walsh
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
last night the media was frantically
reporting the news of a bomb threat at
boston children's hospital now
immediately the left
as you would expect
jumped on the story they were barely
able to hide their glee i mean they were
excited about it because it was an
opportunity to blame uh conservatives
and they blamed conservatives for the
threat mostly singling out libs of tick
tock and myself
um i was tagged thousands of times last
night by leftists condemning me for my
involvement in the bomb threat and uh if
not my involvement then at least my role
in promoting
you know this kind of violence
except that of course i have never
promoted any violence of any kind least
of all have i encouraged anyone to bomb
a hospital
libs of tick tock has done no such thing
either and though i haven't specifically
asked her this question i'm going to go
out on a limb and assume that she agrees
with me and with every other rational
human being on earth that um that you
know bombing hospitals or threatening to
bomb them is evil and insane behavior
now of course this doesn't really need
to be said
everyone knows that we have never
advocated violence and never would
everyone knows that all we have done is
report
what these institutions are doing the
fact that so many children's hospitals
and other medical clinics are doing
terrible things to kids
is a reason to criticize
them not us
the left screams how could you accuse
children's hospitals of drugging and
mutilating kids
well because they are
i mean that that's why we're accused
because that's what they're doing that's
how we can say it
i wish they weren't doing it i wish we
didn't have to talk about it
and that's exactly why i am talking
about it and we'll continue to
but what about the bomb threat well
a funny thing happened
the next morning
the story had gone away completely like
it never happened just gone away
now you might expect that it would be in
the headlines of every mainstream media
outlet that's what i thought
conservative transphobes attack
children's hospital next thing you know
there's a bomb threat right like that's
that's the headline was the headline
tuesday night
by wednesday morning it was gone
and that's because as some outlets
quietly reported much later last night
police quickly determined that the whole
thing was a quote false alarm
in fact according to a report on
boston.com cops showed up to the scene
at 9 20 p.m
and had cleared it by 10 o'clock 40
minutes and they had determined that it
was a false alarm
now this does not seem to mean that
there was really a threat but no bomb
right like somebody called in a threat
and they couldn't find a bomb that's not
what seems to have happened because in
that case you'd think it'd take them a
little bit longer than just over half an
hour to clear the scene
also they would still be looking for the
culprit who made the threat because
making a threat even if there's no bomb
is obviously a crime
but they're not saying that we're
looking for anybody there's no suspect
instead they just moved on and so has
the media
and this leaves a lot of unanswered
questions and raises an even greater
suspicion that
perhaps this was um more uh more you
know less a false alarm and more a hoax
meant to demonize the right
or else maybe it was just a a bag that
somebody
who accidentally left in the corner of a
hallway somewhere
or maybe something else we don't know
we don't know because we haven't given
any more information
and there may be a reason why we haven't
been given any more information whatever
the case
what we can say for sure is that as
always
the left's narrative about the event was
wrong
and it was wrong on several levels
and it was intended to defame me and
others on the right because defamation
and intimidation and emotional blackmail
are the only tools they have available
in their tool chest
what they cannot do
what they steadfastly refuse to do
is engage on the actual topic
and discuss the issue head-on
instead they'll continue to demand that
we stop talking about it while they come
up with ever more elaborate fantasies
about the phantom violence and chaos
we're supposedly causing simply by
talking about it
now it's a clever trick actually because
they claim that children are not being
mutilated that this is all a right-wing
fairy tale and then when we provide
explicit examples to support our claims
they scream that we're promoting
violence
obviously the tactic here is to create
an environment where nobody is allowed
to make a counter-argument the left has
rigged the game completely
they're right about everything and if
you provide evidence to prove they
aren't right then you're a terrorist
which means that well effectively
they're still right
that's that's kind of the uh
the choice that they've given us like
you can either just accept that you're
wrong or you can be a terrorist those
are your two options
what the left says to the right is on
the issue of of tran the transing of
kids either just admit that you're wrong
and we're right
or you're a terrorist those are the only
two options
this is what they resort to because they
cannot defend the indefensible and they
know it
after all
what can anyone really say to vindicate
for example
dr scott mosser of the gender
confirmation center in san francisco
now
the left says that children are not
being surgically transitioned
and yet dr scott mosser in san francisco
has a section on his website titled
adolescent top surgery
mosser assures us that he follows quote
strict guidelines before operating on a
child which means that
he will operate on a child and has many
times
indeed he provides a range of services
to adolescent girls he'll chop their
breasts off if they want to become boys
even though they can't become boys he
also offers non-binary procedures for
those children who desire to be neither
male nor female
all this is outlined on his website it's
right there
chris roofoe has looked into mosser's
business as well and found that he
charges between 8 500 and 10 000 a pop
generating 20 million dollars in revenue
for his clinic
as rufus says gender ideology is a
booming business there's
millions of dollars involved
rafael also dug up this clip of mosser
himself uh describing
his approach and i want you to listen to
every word of this listen
i'm super committed to gender surgery in
the past i used to do cosmetic surgery
i'm a board-certified plastic surgeon
and i've always been drawn to things
that are deeply impactful
in the gcc gender confirmation center in
san francisco we kind of have these like
secret missions now now that it's on a
slide these public secret missions which
are
uh one of them is that we try to we try
to live with our values 30 to 40 years
in the future so and that puts us in a
mindset of
extreme affirmation because affirmation
at that time is a foregone conclusion
this is a time in the future when gender
is just a thing nobody makes a big deal
out of it people are being screened as
children and adolescents for their
gender journey and appropriate steps are
taken to get them involved in a
multi-disciplinary process to get them
where they need to go that's that's the
future
i do not have a minimum age of any sort
in my practice there's no chronological
age that says you don't get surgery now
having said that i don't think i've ever
done a consult on a 12 year old yet but
we would if one came our way we just
haven't had reason to um and then we've
done a number of 13 year olds who are
who we did consults on i think i've done
one or two 13 year old surgeries for the
most part it's 14 and up that by the
time everything comes together plus
insurance approval plus everything that
surgery actually gets completed
um we do not require any particular
identity we only require that somebody
has gender dysphoria and uses a
multi-disciplinary process for us to
assess you have a question please yes
yes say what was the youngest age
a trans masculine kid could consider the
surgery
so there is no youngest age
at all
yes he is he is drawn to things that are
deeply impactful he says now if this man
was not a bloodthirsty butcher we might
be able to linger a bit more on that
statement and reflect on what a
pretentious pompous nothing of a person
you have to be to make it
but there are more important issues here
mosser the butcher of san francisco says
that he would happily chop the breasts
off of a 12 year old child
a kid in seventh grade in fact he would
go even younger than that he says that
there's no minimum age no minimum age at
all
though sadly sadly for him he's never
had the opportunity to get to a child
that young he has had the chance to
surgically mutilate a few 13 year olds
and many more kids who are 14 and up
which is what about 9th grade
remember an 18 year old is not old
enough to understand his student loan
agreement
but 14 year olds are able to knowingly
consent to having their bodies
permanently disfigured
on his website mosser offers an faq
section where he addresses the concern
about post-surgery regret here's what he
says
satisfaction with surgical results is
closely related to the surgeon's skill
patient safety and matching the
procedure to the patient's expectations
what is clear is that transgender
visibility has risen dramatically in
recent years along with a number of
requests for transition surgery it is
exceptionally rare for patients to
regret transitioning genders although
rare regret after surgery is often due
to the patient's unrealistic
expectations or due to the very rare
complications from surgery or
unfortunately due to a poor result
executed by an inexperienced surgeon
this is why dr mosser specializes in
transgender surgery and emphasizes
coordination with the patient's support
teams including physicians family
members partners or close friends
assisting in the transition
exceptionally rare he says
but he well knows that he cannot
possibly know
how common or rare it actually is
because any study that is done about
post-op regret among trans people has
focused on adults who had surgery as
adults and even there the picture is not
nearly so rosy as people like moss or
clam claim not even close which is why
trans people are more suicidal the most
suicidal after surgery in fact but until
recently
here's the point these things were not
being done to children certainly not at
the rate and volume that they are now
how many 40 year olds are walking around
out there who had cosmetic
mastectomies at 14
are there any
and so when mosser performs this
procedure on a child and assures the
child that she almost certainly will not
regret it he is lying to her
he is giving her assurances that he has
no evidentiary basis for
least of all a common sense basis
but what does he care
he makes ten thousand dollars rides off
into the sunset
leaving the child to deal with the
consequences
the whole thing is so evil and grotesque
and indefensible that that even its
advocates would rather not talk about it
in fact they demand
in no uncertain terms
that we not talk about it
and they will do anything anything
to stop us from talking about it
which is why we need to keep
talking about it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so joe biden gave a speech in
pennsylvania near scranton where he
pretends that he grew up um and of
course it involved a fair amount of
nonsensical babbling which you can
always expect from joe biden like there
was this moment where he talks about
working as a lifeguard in a
predominantly black area
where he says for some reason
everyone was good at basketball listen
if i can
just interject for a moment my to see
son beau
he was the attorney general of the state
of delaware
and what he used to do is go down in the
east side the what called the bucket
highest crime rate in the country
there's a place where i used to was the
only white guy that worked as a
lifeguard down in that area the east
side
and you know where you can always tell
where the best basketball in the state
is and the best basketball in the city
is that's where everybody shows up
is that where you met corn pop isn't
that uh the corn pop story was is when
he was a lifeguard wasn't it so this is
now the the origin story is coming
together that's where cornpop was and uh
hey you know he's just interjecting if i
could just interject this racially
stereotypical story very quickly here
um yeah i was the only white guy and uh
and if you're the only white guy that's
how you know people are good at
basketball
all right but he made he made headlines
not so much with that moment but with
this moment
where he repudiates
uh the defund of the police
movement
listen
you know i call it to say for america's
plan
and both your members of congress voted
for it it's based on a simple notion
when it comes to public safety in this
nation the answer is not defund the
police it's fund the police
fund the police
[Applause]
and give them
[Music]
we expect them to do everything
we expect them to be
to protect us to be psychologists and to
be sociology i mean we expect you to do
everything i'm not joking
everything you realize more police
officers are killed dealing with
domestic violence than anything else
you realize that
the point is
we ask so much of you
so much of you
i've not met a cop
who likes a bad cop
there's bad and everything there's lousy
senators there's lousy presidents
there's lousy doctors there's lousy
lawyers no i'm serious
but i don't know
any police officer
that feels good about the fact that
there may be a lousy cop
and i'm tired of not giving the kind of
help they need
well he's right about one thing there
are lousy presidents he certainly has
proven that it might be the most correct
thing he's ever said
into a microphone uh but a couple of
things here first what does it say about
your party
that you can even make a headline by
saying that we should
fund police departments
okay what does it say about your party
that this is a this is an applause line
it's a headline
biden says we should fund police
departments okay a politician 10 years
ago would be greeted with silence
and crickets and kind of confused head
scratching if he got up there and said
you know we should do
we should fund our police departments
uh yeah
of course we should
obviously we should fund them
what else are we going to do
defund them who would want to do that it
would be that insane so
um
i should tell you something about the
the people that you're that are in your
party but but the real point here is is
the effort
to rewrite history
because i said to introduce the clip
that he's repudiating the defund the
police movement that's not exactly
correct actually uh because that's not
what biden and the democrats have been
doing over the past year or so
they're not they haven't been going
around and saying wow you know we really
screwed up with that defund the police
stuff you know that whole thing that i
don't know what got into us that was
crazy
they're not doing that no they've just
they just decided to pretend that they
that it never happened
biden's point here isn't that he's
arguing against his own side holding his
own side to account his point is that
the whole defund the police thing is a
silly false narrative and nobody ever
wanted to do that anyway
if you recall this was a very sudden
when this is what democrats can do
because they have the whole media
mechanism behind them uh that can
support them but they just made this
sudden switch
it was defund the police defund the
police defund the police and then one
day what do you mean no one ever wanted
to defund the police
you were just saying it like 30 seconds
ago no one ever said that what are you
talking about
so that's what this is about it's about
rewriting it's not about correcting you
know
writing the course correcting uh or
anything like that
it's about rewriting history
and that's the message that they want to
send that nobody ever wanted to defund
the police
and yet as this video compilation from
rnc research shows the history is quite
clear and it also shows that this defund
the police madness went all the way up
to the white house let's watch this
so we've been talking about defunding
the police there's some issues that we
ask police to do like mental health
issues or policing in schools and all
the rest that perhaps we can
shuffle some of that money around suck
it up defunding the police has to happen
we need to defund the police mayor eric
garcetti saying take some of the money
from policing about 150 million dollars
i applaud eric garcetti for doing what
he's done not only do we need to
disinvest
foreign police but we need to completely
dismantle the minneapolis police
department so yes defund your butts
defund you yes i support the
reallocation of resources
from nypd we will be moving funding from
the nypd to youth initiatives and social
services they are talking about reducing
the allocation of resources to that
department and i think every single
city in this country ought to be
thinking about the same thing yes i
support the defund movement i'm for
responsible
reallocation of resources and defund the
police i think you do all those other
things you don't need all the money
that's going in the police department so
yeah i mean the spirit of it i i i do
support that
it's a seven minute clip i think you got
it i mean if you remember if you don't
have uh amnesia then then you can recall
how this was
for a brief glimmer in time it was a
mainstream talking point
um on the left
every democrat
with uh with any standing
especially on the national stage
you know came out in support of it
the some version of defunding yeah well
reroute funds
and what made this all the more
egregious aside from just how generally
insane it is is that is that this is
this is coming from democrats
who in every other area
when it comes to any other government
function
they want more funds to go in
and not only that but they but they're
quite clear in every other area
that the only way to fix a problem
when it comes to the government is to
give it more funds the school system
any problem in the school system that
they're willing to acknowledge
how do you fix it
more funds give more money
and then law enforcement is the one area
where they said well if you really want
to fix this
stop giving them money at all just get
rid of it
these people don't want to abolish any
aspect of government except local police
permits the only area
if you doubt they're trying to rewrite
history
here's a report from cbs
tweeted out by one of their reporters
who captioned this
captured it the economy is the top
concern
but how to fight crime and gun violence
ranks high with likely voters and now
biden and democrats are arguing
that they are the tough on crime party
they're the tough on crime let's watch a
little bit of this report
on the airwaves in states like
pennsylvania john fetterman wants to
release convicted murderers from prison
public safety is why i ran for office
and now on the stump i'm opposed to
defunding the police i'm also opposed to
defunding the fbi how to fight crime and
gun violence are taking center stage
during a stop in pennsylvania tuesday
president biden attacked those
republicans who've called for defunding
the fbi in response to its search of
former president donald trump's home in
florida
and denounced republicans who defend
rioters at the u.s capitol on january 6.
you can't be pro-law enforcement and
pro-insurrection
you can't be a party of law and order
and call the people who attacked the
police on january 6 patriots
the increase focused on law enforcement
crime and guns on both sides of the
aisle comes as the majority of likely
voters see crime and guns says very
important
so democrats they're they're they're
actually the tough on crime party
now as i've i've already explained you
there's there's a big difference between
wanting to defund the fbi or even
abolish the fbi and saying that about
local police departments because we know
what local police departments do
even if there's corruption in local
police departments which obviously
sometimes there is
but
uh even if there's corruption we know
what local police departments do we know
why they're necessary we know what
happens when
um they don't have enough funding we
know what happens when they aren't doing
their job either because they got their
hands tied and they're told that they're
not supposed to or whatever
we know what happens like when the
police aren't on the scene we know what
happens because we're seeing it right
now
well what happens if there's no fbi well
let's just say
well hypothetically let's say the the
fbi evaporated tomorrow and it didn't
exist anymore
it does that lead to chaos and anarchy
across the country does it
i don't necessarily see any reason why
it would
especially when there are so many
there's so much there's so much overlap
among these
federal agencies that are engaged in
various alleged forms of law enforcement
it there's so many agencies of with with
people that have guns and badges running
around doing this and that and uh so do
we need all of them how much redundancy
is there that's a good question
there is no question about whether we
need local police departments that's the
difference
now
um
the tough one crime party okay let's
that's interesting so here's a thread
from andy noe
published this yesterday
he says after supporting streetcar
takeovers in portland one of antifa's
friends was killed when a stray bullet
aimed at an elderly driver caught on the
road hit someone on their own side
what a tragedy
auntie are asking for money for the
victim's family
the victim right
um
actually and it might actually be a
tragedy because this this there is a
real victim here which is the elderly
man he continues this video of a street
takeover near the portland expo center
on august 28th shows an elderly driver
in a van trying to flee
the rider shot up his vehicle and shoot
him
so there is a victim the elderly man who
was shot his condition is unknown
bullets by the riders hit two on their
own side killing one police made no
arrests
also on august 28 riders took over
another part of portland for a streetcar
event at the intersection of northeast
72nd and sandy they used flamethrowers
police did not make arrests because of
historic low staffing numbers following
2020 on t for riots
so antifa
are in the street this is not the first
time we've seen this they've been doing
this for years
they take over a street
and if you try to drive down the street
they stop you and if you don't listen to
their orders they will kill you
and
not arrested
if you have people in antifa shooting
people in cars
on video and no arrest is made
oh the democrats are tough on crime all
right
and it's the uh it's the right wing it's
right-wing radicals we have to worry
about
where are the right-wing radicals across
the country you know in the middle of
the street with guns stopping cars and
shooting people at will where is that
happening
all right from uh daley wired says los
angeles county officials said tuesday
that a guaranteed basic income program
has begun to roll out with a thousand
residents now receiving a thousand
dollars a month until 2025.
um
fox la reports the recipients for the
program were chosen randomly out of more
than 180 000 applicants supervisor
sheila cool said that given the number
of county residents who applied it's
abundantly clear that the time has come
for the program
she says i'm confident that we will see
what other pilots have already shown
that a guaranteed basic income by giving
people a bit of financial breathing room
allows them to stabilize their lives and
that of their families
now
uh it's being reported that this is a
universal basic income but it's actually
not universal at all
uh so so it can't really be considered a
pilot program or a test flight for
universal basic income where everybody
gets money that's what universal basic
income is that's what andrew yang was
out yammering about right
um it's give every everybody gets a
certain amount of money
that's not whether that's not what this
actually is
but whether we're talking about a
universal basic income or a guaranteed
basic income which is what they're doing
in los angeles um it's a terrible idea
for a lot of reasons and by the way none
of these reasons
can be mitigated by the fact that lots
of people want it because what we heard
from the
county supervisor there was that well
we offered free money
and lots of people applied and wanted it
so clearly that shows that we need to
have this program
the fact that lots of people want free
money that doesn't surprise i know
people want free money with that i
understand
that in and of itself does not prove
that we should be giving free money to
everybody
that's just like if i
uh you know gave out had cake pieces of
cake and i said hey everybody come get
free cake and the next thing you know
all the cake is gone and i said well
everybody want a cake that obviously
proves that cake is good for you
that means why do people want it if it's
not
now it's actually a terrible idea for
for a lot of reason first of all it's
prohibitively expensive
especially when you try to scale it um
this is why the experiment has failed
where it was tried in finland for
example canada and other places
it actually there's no such thing as
free money it turns out money has to
come from somewhere and uh it's a lot of
money and the money just it's it's the
cost is astronomical and it's
prohibitive so that's one problem the
problem obviously is inflation now
andrew yang when he went around talking
about this he said oh i don't have to
worry about inflation just like we
didn't have to worry about inflation
during the during covid when they were
giving out the stimulus checks to
everybody they said that's not going to
cause inflation next thing you know we
have sky-high inflation
no it's just there are there are some
and i'm and i'm no economist but i know
there are basic economic laws when you
when you give money to everyone then the
prices
uh the laws of supply and demand
the laws of the marketplace
will will always lead to prices going up
uh there's also no oversight on how the
money is spent
so this is a problem with many welfare
programs but especially something like
this
i think what they're doing in los
angeles is that they're giving people a
debit card and just saying well here you
go
and
maybe some people will spend it
responsibly a lot of people are going to
go you know you go buy cigarettes and
alcohol and that sort of thing
it's hard to see how that helps
but the biggest issue
is disincentivizing
work
okay and this is another thing that we
saw during cove when you start giving
money to everyone and you know expanding
and extending unemployment extending it
again and again and again
making it more and more comfortable for
people to not work than what happens
people don't work
and when you're not in when you don't
have people working then society starts
to break down
businesses can't stay open
businesses start closing then
the the the things that people need are
not available to them anymore
because there's no one there to provide
them
in order for them to be provided you
need people to work
now what the left is always trying to do
is get around the fact
that life requires work
this is why i always feel i always have
to give my dad speech because this is a
speech that many people on the left
never got because they weren't raised by
dead they had dads in the home it's one
of the problems here
there's a classic dad speech about
uh
you you have to work that's that's
that's life
there's no way around it
and the more
comfortable
you make people in not working the worse
things are
and the more strain you put on the few
people remaining who do work
because again this is a this is a basic
fact of life in order for you to survive
um
there has to be work done to prop up
your existence
and if you are not going to do it then
someone else has to do it
if nobody at all is doing any kind of
work then everyone just dies that's it
the only way around that is for some
people to not works and then forcing
other people to work for them
working for themselves and others as
well
[Music]
um
and i don't know
i think we know historically that
systems where you force people to work
for you
are highly unethical let's just say
all right moving to this talk about
rewriting history here is governor tim
waltz uh democrat in minnesota
talking about
the the shutdown of schools
you remember that don't you just like we
remember the the defund the police
movement
well apparently it never happened did
you know that this we we hallucinated it
the schools were never actually shut
down listen to the governor
would you have done the schools any
differently because i think that's where
a lot of parents are upset about what
happened with the schools well do you
think you could have made any other
choice well i think just to be clear
over 80 percent of our students miss
less than 10 days of in-class learning
the vast majority of students were in it
depended again on population density
many of these decisions were being made
by local folks to be able to do what was
necessary to keep them there
i think again in hindsight
um if if we could have known that we
would get vaccinations out as quickly as
possible we prioritize teachers and the
staff in schools to get there um we're
doing it differently now and since
may of
2021 almost every one of our students
has been in the entire time and been
doing that so
i think with hindsight as 2020 perhaps
we could have tailored a little bit
closer to that but the fact of the
matter is making the case that we
shouldn't have done anything is simply
wrong
oh man it's got to be so good to be a
democrat it's just no accountability you
could say anything at all
uh and it's got to be so nice
um
it's the exact opposite situation for
being you know on the right where every
word you say publicly people are sifting
through it and every little statement is
getting pulled apart and fact checked
and everything but you're on the left
you don't have that at all you could
just say anything else so he could sit
there and
say that 80 percent of students missed
fewer than 10 days of in of in class
learning
what
that the schools were shut down at a
minimum
for
the remainder of 2020 after covet hit
and that's that's on the lower end of it
and then if we recall
going going to the into the school
system after the school season after the
the summer
um it was a big fight about whether
schools were going to open and in many
places such as in minnesota they didn't
so we said kids uh well they didn't they
they they missed less than 10 days no
they missed like a year
and he even admits that later on because
he says well as of may of 2021 kids have
been in school yeah but covet hit in
march of 2020.
there's over a year in between that
governor
and whoever's interviewing him let's get
lets him get away with that i only
missed 10 days what are you talking
about
that's what it should have been
um that's what we were originally told
well no we were told 15 days right so
this way i do 15 days and we'll get back
to our lives
it's amazing that we always thought like
how are they gonna they told us 15 days
of slow spread it became it became 300
days or whatever um how are they going
to account for that well they're just
going to pretend that it really was 15
days
um
all right i wanted to mention this too
so the daily wire
says gibson's bakery a family-owned
bakery that has operated in oberlin ohio
since 1885
received a major win in its ongoing feud
with oberlin college
which encouraged and supported students
and faculty falsely accusing the bakery
of racism in 2016.
so the jury awarded the bakery 36
million dollars in damages after
oberlin's sustained campaign against the
shop and the college fought the verdict
with every tool at its disposal the
state supreme court on tuesday declined
to hear oberlin's appeal meaning the
school will finally have to pay the
bakery that it has nearly put out of
business
gibson's family attorney told the daily
wire to statement truth still matters
david can still overcome goliath we in
the gibson family are gratified that all
judges on the court of appeals the
majorities the ohio supreme court
recognize the rights of individuals
rather than the bullying tactics of the
big institutions
in april an appeals court upheld the
multi-million dollar verdict the daily
wire reported but the college appealed
to the
ohio supreme court and uh they lost
there as well so they're going to have
to pay out
36 million
in damages
for having
almost put this business out of business
now
what happened here that's that's the end
of the story that's the happy ending and
we don't get a lot of those so we should
celebrate them when they happen
but what led to this if you don't
remember this story because there are so
many fake racism stories it's hard to
keep them all
straight
why was this bakery being accused of
racism
well it's very simple actually you can
tell the story in like two sentences
some non-white oberlin students
went to the business few years ago
tried to steal alcohol from the business
they were stealing
someone at the bakery in the gibson
family stopped them from stealing
and that's it
that's where it'll start that's why
they're racist
because a white person at a business
tried to stop some non-white people from
stealing from them and
therefore they're racist
next you know there are protests there's
everything else and oberlin college
itself as an institution
is putting all of its weight behind
destroying this business and these
people
simply because they wouldn't allow black
students to steal from them
why else would you stop someone from
stealing from you except racism
right because because the the gibson
family
they invite white people to steal from
them they have a sign on the door saying
uh white people are allowed to steal
if they saw a white person walking out
the door with something they'd say oh
hey stop sir oh wait you're white never
mind go ahead go ahead do you want more
you want to grab this over here you can
have that as well you want some money
from the cash register i mean if you're
white you can have it
that's basically the the situation that
the that's the picture that oberlin
college as an institution wanted to
paint and now they got to pay out
which is
great but it's also um
discouraging on an in in another way if
you want to look at the if you want to
look at the black cloud within the
silver lining as i often tend to do um
it's also kind of discouraging because
of what
they were so clearly defamed and
victimized here they're so clearly the
in the right so clearly the victims and
yet it took them years and i don't know
how much money to be vindicated and most
people who are
put in this situation don't have the
resources to fight like that
and so they're defamed and their lives
are destroyed and then the mob just
moves on to the next person
all right let's uh let's brighten the
mood a little bit i want you to watch
this this is something inspiring here's
a man entering a girls basketball
tournament uh this is not someone who as
far as i know identifies as trans this
is just a dude it's just a dude who
decided to take advantage of our current
mania and have some fun with it and
here's what that looked like
about to literally make history time to
go for 30. oh my god cuddy
dynasty don't break my nails
raise the roof
oh
you're not doing that again
good pass yeah we outside shot our whole
team moves
i'm not worried
oh
that is inspiring i mean this is
a brave and bold young lady
she is a a hero for living her truth
uh and i and i hope she goes on to
dominate the wnba that's what i hope
a true pioneer
don't don't stop here young lady
continue
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
um i'll tell you one thing before we get
to the comments because this is another
thing i'm going through in my life and i
think it'll be important for you to hear
so two nights ago it's about 11 30. um
my wife is in bed
and she's not asleep yet i don't think
but even if she was i had like i talked
about something was really important
and i told her that i've been
really bothered
for a long time now by the fact that my
socks which are very important to me
always get lost in the wash now everyone
knows this it's a classic complaint of
course you put a pair of socks in the
wash and somehow only one emerges right
we all know that
and for someone like myself it puts a
lot of thought and effort
and love into building a sock collection
this is a very challenging thing for me
so i i so what i was trying to explain
to my wife is like i came up with a
system
and uh and i was trying to tell her this
at 11 30 at night i bought a special
sock bag on amazon and the system is
that i will as i explained to her
throughout the week i'll deposit my
socks the you know both pairs of socks
after i use them into the bag which will
remain in my closet until the end of the
week at which point the socks will be
while still in the back will be
transported to
the laundry room and now here's where
things get tricky because the bag is
porous my hope is that they can be
washed inside the bag
and then that way we know we're not
gonna have any problems if that doesn't
work then they'll be taken out of the
bag put into the wash
then to the dryer and then transported
back to my sock drawer though not put
them back inside the bag because that's
for my dirty socks right
the most important point here is that
they never go in a hamper ever
under any circumstance and they must not
be washed with other items because when
you do that that's when you lose them
and they're just lost okay and a pair of
socks that i bought or that i got from
my sock subscription service which i do
have
um is is now gone and so this is the
system i came up with i'm trying to
explain all this to her
and she just
starts
laughing at me and making fun of my
quote girly sock bag
and then she said well if it's so
important to you just wash the socks
yourself
to which i said
let's not get carried away here okay
this is a team team effort
and it just goes to show that sometimes
here's the point that's why i'm telling
you this
sometimes in a marriage your priorities
don't always match up
and that's where some challenges can but
we're going to work through this
together
whether she likes it or not we're going
to keep talking about the sock problem
until we have a solution
that's that's teamwork in a marriage um
kayla says
i can't believe people were arguing with
matt about uh his statement on well you
could just you could stop right there i
can't believe people are arguing with
matt is and that's enough
i agree with you i can't believe they're
arguing about the homeless people i work
at a mental health agency as a crisis
worker and every week homeless people
come to us asking for housing after
they've already been kicked out of every
shelter for either drug use or fighting
uh they get mad when we tell them that
we can't help them when they've already
gone through every community resource i
would feel so i would feel so sorry for
any hotel owner forced to give them free
rooms
and destroy their business
yeah you could just
this is to talk to anyone who's worked
with with homeless people
which is an admirable uh
vocation of course an important one but
you talk to anyone who's
worked in that environment and there's
just no question
no argument about it drug use mental
illness all these things um you you
[Music]
as i as i've been saying
there's a there's a reason people end up
homeless and it's not simply
uh social injustice and it's it's very
rarely is it a matter of simple
misfortune or bad luck
uh there's a there's a deeper reason and
you don't have to work with a particular
homeless person for very long to figure
out what the reason is
most of the time it's drugs
um
kathy with a c says if i ever find
myself laying on an operating table i
want the most diverse or staff hovering
over my exposed innards only then will i
know that our country has made real
progress that is yeah when you go just
like anything else right you're going
into an operation you want to make sure
that's what you're thinking about how
diverse is this stuff
you get onto an airplane
that's the most important thing to you
is we're we're disadvantaged minorities
given an opportunity to fly this plane
that's all i care about
um
let's see
back ghetto latina
that's latinx
first of all back ghetto latinx
casseville isn't the only school to do
this my school uh kids school has had
this in effect since before they started
there uh that's corporal punishment
referring to the oldest is in seventh
grade the administrators had to use it
once years before my kids started the
fear kept them in check castville is a
heavy republican district it's a rural
area just like my area even with the
permission slip the administration has
to call the parents to make sure it's
okay and tell them what their child has
done they're supposed to be a staff
member removed from the situation that
uses the paddle with a witness present
to make sure it's not overdone
it's a last resort
again i can understand the
inclination especially among schools to
have a kind of last resort because all
the other disciplinary methods don't
work
but like we talked about yesterday that
just
among other things it requires
a trust
between parents and and the school
officials that i certainly wouldn't have
if my kids were going to public school
i'm not gonna i just can't trust you to
use physical force on my child i can't
there are so many reasons why i can't
trust you
and also my other question is
if you as a parent
would approve
corporal punishment being used against
your child by a school official
then that tells me that you have no
problem with corporal punishment so then
why wouldn't you just
be the one to administer it
so i no matter how you slice it i don't
understand farming it out to the school
system
many questions
you know the time is upon us for another
backstage happening tonight at 6 p.m
central 7 pm eastern and it's about time
because there's more news than ever to
discuss if you've never seen backstage
before it's where i get together with my
daily wire cohorts including ben shapiro
matt matt walsh me i'm i'm one of the
cohorts just keep going doesn't matter
no no we'll keep going uh including ben
shapiro matt walsh michael knowles
andrew clavin and god king jeremy borg
so who is supposed to be giving this
copy if if i just listed all the cohorts
so who's this copy written for
anyway jokes will be cracked cigars will
be smoked
copy will be butchered libations will be
imbibed you definitely don't want to
miss this one so tune in to join us for
backstage tonight at 6 pm central 7 pm
eastern
dailywireplus.com
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know many conservatives when we are
younger we will inevitably
experiment with libertarianism we dabble
in that uh
particular political ideology finding
that it appeals to our young
underdeveloped brains we start answering
every difficult social question with the
statement hey man just get the
government out of it we buy the book
atlas shrugged and tell everyone that we
read it even though we never even
glanced at the first page um
these are the follies of youth and most
of us as we get older
we grow out of that phase and we feel
embarrassed by it the same way that
people who grew up in the 70s feel
embarrassed about having owned a pet
rock and the way people that grew up in
the 80s should feel embarrassed about
well everything that happened in that
decade but there are some grown adults
who
sadly
never graduate
they never evolved they never grow out
of it
they end up looking as ridiculous and
awkward as a 50 year old man in a
backwards hat and that's what brings us
to
kim iverson who's a pundit of some kind
with a decent social media following who
seems to have attracted an audience of
of conservatives who believe that she's
on their side largely because she
doesn't like the vaccine and she says
nice things about donald trump those are
the two things i've noticed uh
apparently and maybe there are other
things as well but those two things in
particular have attracted conservatives
to her and that's why she has some kind
of audience i don't know how big it is
and that's all well and good
but it won't save her
now that she has torched her credibility
and revealed herself to be an amoral
idiot
and every other kind of idiot too
kim responded to my tweet about dr scott
mosser the butcher who chops the breasts
off of adolescent girls
with this rebuttal this is what she said
it's their body their choice
if their parents or anyone is pressuring
them let them live with that and take it
up with them later it's none of our
business how others choose to live their
lives
yes her response to doctors removing the
body parts of physically healthy
children is their body their choice
from here kim launched into a series of
tweets frantically searching for some
way to defend cosmetic double
mastectomies on teen girls she had just
she had thrown down the gauntlet
put down her marker climbed atop the
girls should have their breast removed
hill and decided that
she would die on it that's what it took
reading through the tweets that to
follow she she wrote um just going
through a series of these 16 year old
girls get nose jobs all the time where's
your outrage
shoulda woulda coulda again personal
choice i'm all for personal freedom live
and let live even if it leads to regret
if it's what they want to do it's what
they want to do
i'm not for controlling others because i
personally think it's morally wrong
you guys we're talking about boob jobs
let's keep things in perspective it's
literally none of your business if a
woman chooses to enlarge them or shrink
them
from there she became even more inc
incoherent and desperate accusing me of
being a triggered snowflake for opposing
the mutilation of children which by the
way kim yes i am i am triggered by child
abuse i i admit i'm triggered by it i i
find it quite upsetting even i i'm even
offended by i am offended
by the brutalization of children i am i
admit it
and then she started crying that she was
the victim of conservative cancel
culture because people were criticizing
her for her views
finally in one last blow to whatever
credibility she may have still been
clinging to uh she asserted that not
only can minors consent to having their
breasts removed but they can also
consent to sex she posted quote
minors actually can consent to sex each
state has its own laws on this
later that night she posted a lengthy
twitter thread trying to defend her to
pray views in more detail writing quote
today proved it conservatives are no
different than woke liberals they just
choose different topics to be outraged
over and in their minds just like to
woke liberals this is different this is
immoral and must be stopped
my stance is clear i don't think the
government should interfere or be
involved in the consensual medical
decisions of others i don't know what
others are going through and i don't
believe that i nor the government should
be telling others what's best for them
yes who's to say what's best for anyone
if a girl's having her breasts chopped
off maybe that's best for if a kid is
playing in the street about to get hit
by a truck don't interfere after all
it's what he wants to do and it may be
best for him who are we to impose our
anti getting hit by truck views on that
child that would be rude that would be
oppressive
indeed if we were to prevent the child
from being killed in traffic we'd be no
better than woke leftists
constantly trying to impose our
subjective views on others what are you
some kind of snowflake outrage about
kids getting hit by cars you snowflake
cancel culture you're trying to cancel
people who hit who who hit children with
their cars stop cancelling them
great points kim
you have the moral insight of a lizard
and you should be quite proud
now
there's too much nonsense here to handle
but we'll we'll do our best to pick
through it
first of all to clarify our terms here
top surgery quote unquote is a double
mastectomy
a double mastectomy is not a boob job
the breasts are not being enlarged nor
are they being reduced
they're being removed
the breast tissue the mammary glands all
of it is being cut off
the procedure unlike breast implants
which i also would oppose for children
because i'm not a disgusting creep
but unlike implants a mastectomy is not
reversible a person who has this
procedure and regrets it as many do and
many many more will
as this current crop of children become
adults
they they can for a large fee try to
reconstruct some approximation of
something that looks like female breasts
but they will never have female breasts
ever again they'll never be able to
nurse their children
all of that is gone forever
based on a choice they made when they
were adolescents
but can they make a choice like that as
a child
that's the question kim says they can
and she cites the fact that the age of
consent in some states is 16.
now the problem with this approach is
that first of all children are being
subjected to medical and surgical gender
transitions much younger than 16. dr
scott mosser is doing it at 14 at 13. he
would do it at 12. he would do it in at
any age
second the age of consent in california
is 18. yet dr scott mosser is operating
in california
on on girls who allegedly consent to
having their breasts removed at 16 or
younger
third even if the age of consent is 16
in some states like in vermont i think
it's 16 for example
um
does that mean that it's actually
morally right automatically i mean is it
the age of consent in in sick in vermont
is 16. so is it okay for a 50 year old
man to have sex with a 16 year old in
that state
just because that's what it says on
paper
what would you say about such a man kim
what if you had a 16 year old daughter
you'd be okay with her date dating a 50
year old
because how she can do what she wants an
age of consent
actually don't answer that question
don't tell me how you feel about it
because i don't want to know
now this may come as a shock to you kim
but
did you know
did you know this
uh and again maybe make sure you're
sitting down for this part this is this
is going to surprise you
laws
can be wrong
did you know that there are times when
laws allow things that they shouldn't
allow
the law allowed slavery at one time
the law has allowed many terrible things
right now the law in many states allows
yes it does
doctors to castrate and butcher children
that's true
but the law is wrong
and we know that it's wrong because no
matter what any politician wrote onto a
piece of paper certain scientific and
moral truths remain one of those truths
is that a child does not have a fully
developed brain that's a fact she's not
capable of making fully informed
decisions she's not capable of thinking
through the consequences of her actions
she does not she's not capable of it she
does not have the maturity and
competence or or brain chemistry
required to be entrusted with permanent
life-altering decisions this is a fact
confirmed by neurology
and also by the experience of every
adult human who has ever lived on earth
because we've all been 16 at one time
and so we know these things
what this means is that it's not
possible for a child to make a
consensual medical decision as you say
the statement makes no sense
they cannot consent to what they do not
understand
now there are moral truths too
one of those moral truths is that it is
wrong to harm a child
that is wrong to do
it doesn't matter what the law says
doesn't matter what the law allows
doesn't even matter what the child says
it is wrong to harm a child causing
permanent severe physical damage
is the worst kind of physical harm
possible short of outright murder
now if you don't think that we can make
moral determinations like this then i
mean what do you support should we
repeal all of the child abuse laws in
the country
maybe you would support that
the libertarian mind virus seems to be
terminal in your case so there's no
telling how far you would go
now you say that conservatives are are
no different than woke liberals because
we declare this is different this is
immoral it must be stopped
but but um what you fail to understand
kim is that
some things are different from other
things
not all things are the same
some things are there are things that
are one thing and then you have
something else that's different from
that thing
some things actually are immoral and
really must be stopped
just because woke liberals make moral
claims and demand that certain things be
stopped
that doesn't mean that all moral claims
are automatically wrong and that nothing
at all should be stopped
the problem with the woke liberal is not
that he condemns certain behavior
it's that he is wrong about what he
condemns
he is morally confused
and so are you and in that way you are
like the woke liberal which is why both
of you find yourselves defending the
most grotesque form of child abuse the
world has ever seen
you are right about one thing though i
do practice my own form of cancer
culture
that's what this segment is all about
and it's why you have found yourself in
it and it's also why you today are
unfortunately canceled
and that'll leave it
there for us for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if we don't
godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you